anti-transgender bills are sweeping the
country right Wingers are obsessed this
is what they call a culture War we call
it a campaign of persecution and a move
in the continued authoritarian direction
that these right-wingers have gone in
for some time but it is
anti-transgender sentiment that is now
fueling much of what we are seeing among
cultural right-wingers I don't even want
to call them cultural conservatives
cultural conservatism might be like oh I
don't know my wife makes dinner four out
of seven weeks uh four out of seven days
of the week or whatever like this is not
cultural conservatism this is something
very very different and vice has a
report on new data released by the trans
legislation tracker there are it's
February there are already twice as many
anti-trans bills making their way
through State legislatures as what we
saw in 2022
and in fact this legislative session
that started on January 1st this
calendar year of legislation has seen
more than 350 anti-trans bills
introduced in 36 States compared with
170 in all of 2022. we are six weeks
into the year so last year was a
record-breaking year and this year is
already doubling it and only 6 out of 52
weeks through the year anti-trans bills
are being proposed at the state level we
are seeing them at the national level we
are seeing municipalities push this
stuff and this includes everything from
proposed legislation in Wyoming which
would equate gender affirming care to
child abuse despite the fact that every
serious medical Authority has said oh no
no gender affirming care is good
it improves outcomes and well-being
um we have seen bills that just try to
narrow and codify biological definitions
for man and woman and so far three
different states we've seen this in
Tennessee we see it in South Dakota we
we see it in Utah have already passed
bans on gender affirming care the South
Dakota bill that was passed into law has
an element in it which can force trans
youth to detransition at least as far as
the state is concerned in Oklahoma
there's a proposal for a bill which
would ban gender affirming care if
you're under 26 there was a bill
attempted in North Dakota but it failed
which would fine teachers if they use
the pronouns preferred by the trans
person trans person says you know I go
by she even though I was born
biologically male teacher says okay
I'll do that teacher can get fined based
on the bill that fortunately failed in
North Dakota
so this is a very serious issue and this
is a serious issue even if you are
someone in my audience and I know that
there are some of you who aren't yet
really totally sure where you land on
all aspects of what's going on in the
trans community and let me tell you you
can say as I do we still got to figure
out when it comes to some sports when
we're talking about uh trans women
really right because remember even the
sports issue you've got all trans issues
and then within that you have issues
related to sports and then within that
you have issues related to trans women
in sports and then within that it's only
some sports
nobody's getting all shaken up about oh
you know what uh there there's a trans
woman who wants to play with the women
in chess I've not heard anybody bring
that issue up it's some sports only
trans women okay so this is a very very
narrow issue you can take the position
that you're not yet sure how that should
be dealt with
that's totally fine while still
recognizing that the 99 of all of this
legislation that's being proposed is
dangerous and it's the new scapegoat as
we talked about you know I did an
interview
for some of our other platforms with a
drag performer earlier this week which
we're going to be publishing for you
soon and in that interview we talk about
how the tropes have shifted from many of
the ones used against gay men 15 or so
years ago when I started interviewing
some of the homophobes they've shifted a
lot of the same stuff over uh to trans
people and it's oh you know a sexual
assault and pedophilia bathrooms you got
to be worried about the bathrooms this
is just shifting the hate to Target
trans people and their families and one
of the things that we're seeing
and it's horrible that this is happening
is in some states Texas Alabama Arkansas
we are seeing families with trans kids
moving moving out moving out of the
states all together and
um this is potentially going to go in a
very very dark Direction and one of the
reasons that these bills uh are
dangerous is that they really push the
boundaries of demonizing trans people by
codifying that this is a group that's a
problem we need to pass special laws
because this group is so problematic and
this is going to expand and we know it's
going to expand because it is expanding
it used to be just about bathrooms now
it's about what are teachers allowed to
say if they don't want to get fined it's
about so many things beyond that so I'm
putting it on your radar this is all to
fix problems that really don't exist
the issue of oh
people will pretend to be trans to go
into bathrooms to spy on people in
stalls of it's not happening it's not
happening and that's against the law no
matter what your uh agenda identity is
and it is not an issue it just doesn't
exist and then lastly this anti-trans
group it's not a group in the collective
anti-trans movement
um also wants many of us to believe that
gender affirming care is harmful but
there's extensive research from medical
governing bodies the American Medical
Association American Psychological
American Psychiatric association
American Academy of Pediatrics they have
endorsed gender affirming care even for
minors when you go through the correct
protocol now the right will say they're
chopping off the breasts of prepubescent
women
well they're not women and they don't
have breasts if they're prepubescent and
it's really not happening and when push
comes to shove they really struggle to
present any data that suggests that this
is an epidemic but it doesn't matter
it's about what can you trick people
into believing so we're going to follow
it extraordinarily closely and it is
just as scary as it sounds not exactly
small government